[Music]
when we think of viruses
we often think of the biological agents
responsible for influenza
ebola or the covid19 pandemic
the damage caused by these viruses on
society is significant
but why do viruses infect us what role
do they have in biology
and is there a way we can harness
viruses to benefit humanity
let's start by looking at what a virus
is
viruses are small infectious agents made
up of genetic material
either dna or rna surrounded by a
protective protein layer called
the capsid the capsid is made up of
identical building blocks known as
that fit together to make the 3d
structure of the virus
these can be classified into
non-enveloped viruses
that can have complex helical or
icosahedral figure
and enveloped viruses which are
spherical
as a capsid is surrounded by a membrane
unlike most other biological agents
viruses can't reproduce
on their own instead they infect a host
cell
hijack the cell's machinery and force it
to produce new viruses
the type of virus determines how it gets
inside a cell
some non-enveloped viruses have proteins
on their surface
that bind to receptors on the outside of
cells
think of the viral surface protein as a
key that fits into the lock on the
cell's surface
if the protein fits the cell is unlocked
and the virus can enter
other non-enveloped viruses attach to
the outside of the cell
and essentially poke a needle through
the membrane to deposit viral genetic
material inside
enveloped viruses on the other hand are
surrounded by a membrane like the one on
cells
this allows the virus to fuse with the
cell releasing the capsid inside
regardless of the strategy viruses use
to enter the cell
the process that follows is the same the
viral genetic
material ends up at the ribosomes the
cellular machinery
that will translate the viral genetic
material into proteins
these come together to form new viruses
which can leave the cell
either by pushing through the membrane
or by lysing it
which can eventually lead to cell death
the human body has natural defenses
against viruses
such as immune cells that attack them
and antibodies that bind to them
after a virus is successfully eliminated
the immune system retains a memory of
the pathogen
this way the next time the same virus
infects us
our bodies can respond faster and more
efficiently
unfortunately our bodies are not always
capable of eliminating the virus
in this case the best way to protect
ourselves is through vaccines
a form of artificial immunity that
involves administering
low doses of weakened viruses to the
body
this mimics the process of natural
immunity allowing the body to generate a
memory of the virus
without the vaccinated individual
actually developing the disease
when no vaccine or treatment exists and
the body cannot mount a sufficient
attack
on its own we are at risk of the virus
replicating out of control
and spreading throughout the population
a prime example of this
is the covid19 pandemic caused by the
novel coronavirus
sars kov2 this virus is thought to be
zoonotic
meaning it was first transmitted from
animals to humans
the first outbreak was recorded in wuhan
china in december of 2019
and the virus quickly spread across the
globe infecting over 20 million people
and killing over 820 000 as of august
2020 despite the harm that viruses can
cause most of them don't actually infect
humans
in fact some are critical to our
survival bacteriophages for instance
are complex viruses that help us fight
off harmful bacteria they hijack the
bacteria that are infecting the body
and force them to halt the production of
harmful bacterial components
stopping the damage that the bacteria
were causing
since bacteriophages do not damage our
cells in the process
they have been used to fight bacterial
infections like e coli
and staph as bacteria become more
resistant to antibiotics
antibiotics can fail in protecting us
which is where
bacteriophages can become especially
useful
with new technology we are learning how
to harness viruses
to use them for our benefit nowadays we
treat some as
messenger vessels by removing the
potentially dangerous genes viruses
would insert
to our dna and replacing them with
sequences
that can be useful for us for example
the herpes virus has been used to treat
cancer
by replacing the genetic material of the
virus with new dna
that can target and attack tumor cells
although there's still a lot to be
learned about viruses
it is becoming clear that they can be
more than just the diseases they are
known to cause
they might even become the next
superheroes of medicine
[Music]
you